أريد أن أخبركم الآن عن دولة
يخشى الكثيرون أنها قد تكون التالية في
مواقع فلاديمير بوتين، وقد
أعرب وزير الخارجية بلينكن يوم الجمعة عن
قلقه العميق بشأن المؤامرات الروسية لزعزعة
استقرار الحكومة هناك، إنها
أمة فقيرة صغيرة تقع إلى الجنوب الغربي
من أوكرانيا.  يوجد بداخلها
منطقة انفصالية مدعومة من روسيا،
الأمة التي أتحدث عنها هي مولدوفا، وهي
مسقط رأسي، لذا ما الذي
يحدث هناك، دعنا
نحضر الصحفية المولدوفية باولا أريزونا
لتشرح لبول أنه من الرائع رؤيتك
مرحبًا بك  للبرنامج، لذلك دعونا نعطي
جمهورنا لمحة عما حدث في
الأسابيع القليلة الماضية فقط، حيث
قدم الرئيس زيلينسكي الأسبوع الماضي بعض المعلومات
الاستخبارية وشارك الأدلة مع
الرئيسة المولدوفية مايا ساندو حول
محاولة مؤامرة روسية للقيام بانقلاب
للإطاحة بالحكومة هناك  في نهاية
الأسبوع الماضي فقط، قدمت المزيد من
الأدلة وقالت إن هذا هو
الحال بالفعل ووصفتها بأنها
حرب هجينة تهدف إلى زعزعة استقرار المجتمع، هل
يمكنك أن تعطينا المزيد من المعلومات حول ما
يحدث،
نعم، لذا ذكرت الرئيسة مايا ساندو
أن المؤامرة ستشمل أشخاصًا لديهم
التحضير العسكري يأتي بعضهم
من الخارج من أجل إثارة العنف
واقتحام مؤسسات الدولة
واحتجاز الرهائن
أثناء احتجاجات المعارضة هنا
أيضًا، كما أكد مستشار زيلينسكي مايكل بودولاك
هذا النوع من التفاصيل
قائلاً إن خطة روسيا الجديدة
لمولدوفا لا تتضمن في الواقع دبابات ولكن
قطاع الطرق كان
يقصد بهذا النوع من زعيم
المعارضة من حزب
شور إيلان شور الموالي للكرملين والذي يواجه اتهامات
بغسل الأموال في مولدوفا
وبالتالي فر إلى إسرائيل ولكن في هذه الأثناء
ينظم حزبه في مولدوفا
احتجاجات جماهيرية.  اليوم
ويظهر من خلال بث فيديو مباشر
خلال هذه الاحتجاجات، ما يجعلنا
أكثر قلقًا يجب أن نلاحظه هو أن
الحكومة المولدوفية (
الحكومة الحالية) هي حكومة موالية للغرب،
فهل نعرف ما إذا كان قد تم إحباط محاولة الانقلاب هذه
بنجاح أم لا
؟  تحدثنا خلال الأسبوع الماضي عن
عدم السماح لنحو 60 مواطنًا أجنبيًا
بدخول البلاد، بعضهم
قالوا إنهم
قاموا
بتزوير أوراق
بأسماء مختلفة
وجنسيات مختلفة، وقام
المزيد من الشرطة بدوريات في
الشوارع
ونوع وزارة
الشؤون الداخلية التي تم إطلاق سراحها  هذا النوع من الخطط
للملاجئ في حالة حدوث أي نوع من
حالات الطوارئ، لذلك يبدو أن
مؤسسات الدولة قد تم تكثيف
أعمالها
واتصالاتها التي كانت أكثر فقراً في
الماضي.
أصبحت روسيا مرشحة لموظفي الاتحاد الأوروبي،
أعني أن مولدوفا أصبحت
مرشح للحصول على عضوية الاتحاد الأوروبي، وقد
قيل إنها دولة ضعيفة للغاية، إنها
دولة فقيرة للغاية، وأعتقد أن
ميزانية الدفاع العسكري تبلغ حوالي
80 مليون دولار سنويًا فقط، وأنا أعلم أن
ذلك أدى إلى الكثير من الصراعات الداخلية
أيضًا والتحديات الاقتصادية.  يبلغ
التضخم حوالي 27 في المائة. ما هو
التهديد الأكبر هل هو القضايا الداخلية
المتعلقة بالاقتصاد أم أنه
التهديد الخارجي ربما من موسكو؟
حسنًا، الاثنان مترابطان لذا في
الوقت الحالي بالطبع أصبح الناس أكثر
اهتمامًا بحياتهم اليومية.
صراعات اقتصادية ولكن في نفس الوقت يحاول هذا النوع
من المعارضة الموالية للكرملين
الاستفادة
من هذه القضايا الاقتصادية
ويطلبون من الحكومة دفع ما يقرب من
100 من فواتير الشتاء وما إلى ذلك، ومن
الواضح أنه إذا
كانت هناك حكومة مؤيدة لأوروبا في مولدوفا  تم استبدالها
بأخرى مؤيدة للكرملين، ثم سيتم
استخدام مولدوفا في الحرب ضد أوكرانيا من قبل
روسيا لأنه من الواضح أن لدينا أيضًا
ترانسنيسترا في الشرق، وهي
منطقة انفصالية يتمركز فيها 1500 جندي روسي
وحيث لا يزال هناك 20 ألف طن من
الذخيرة والذخيرة الجوية السوفيتية
مخزنة.
حتى هذه اللحظة، لا تزال روسيا تزود
مولدوفا بالغاز، حيث يأتي حوالي 70 بالمائة
من الكهرباء من
منطقة ترانسنيستريا الانفصالية، تلك المنطقة الموالية لروسيا
أيضًا، وأنا أعلم أن الحلفاء الغربيين
سارعوا
للدفاع عن مولدوفا وتقديم المزيد من المساعدات، هل
يكفي ذلك؟  جعل مولدوفا تترك أخيرًا
قبضة روسيا وربما تنضم إلى الاتحاد الأوروبي،
لذلك كانت المساعدات الخارجية مفيدة في
تعويض فواتير الناس هذا الشتاء
ولكن لم يتم تعويضهم بنسبة
مائة بالمائة، كما تعلم أن
المتظاهرين اليوم كانوا يطالبون
الحكومة
يقولون أنهم يريدون الاستثمار في المزيد من
الطاقة الخضراء وتنويع
مصادر الكهرباء ولكن
التضخم في الوقت الحالي لا يزال هو
الأعلى في أوروبا والناس
يكافحون من أجل سداد رهونهم العقارية
أو لدفع فواتيرهم
أو لتغطية نوع ما  التكاليف الأساسية
والأشخاص الذين تحدثت إليهم قالوا
إنهم يفكرون في الهجرة،
لدينا جميعًا بالفعل مشكلة مع عدد قليل جدًا
من الموارد البشرية هنا، هناك
جالية كبيرة في الشتات تبحث عن المزيد من
الفرص الاقتصادية خارج
مولدوفا في الاتحاد الأوروبي.
أي قلق عندما
شنت روسيا هجومها الجديد من أنها قد
تقوم بعمل عسكري ضد مولدوفا،
أعرفها أنه كان هناك خوف من ذلك في وقت
مبكر من الحرب. أنا
آسف، هل يمكنك تكرار ذلك، هل هناك
أي قلق الآن حيث شنت روسيا عملية عسكرية؟
هجوم جديد في أوكرانيا أنها يمكن أن
تقوم بأي نوع من المحاولة العسكرية في
مولدوفا. كانت هناك مخاوف من ذلك في وقت
مبكر من الحرب.
نعم هناك قول مأثور في مولدوفا بأننا
نعتمد على أوديسا وأوديسا تعتمد
على نيكولاييف ولكن لدينا أيضًا
أم  الجنوب معرض
للخطر
حتى الآن، وقد تمت حماية مولدوفا من قبل
الجيش الأوكراني، وحقيقة أن
الجيش الأوكراني تمكن من نقل
خط المواجهة إلى الغرب قد أدى
إلى نوع من تهدئة الروح المعنوية في مولدوفا،
وأصبح الناس أكثر هدوءًا نتيجة لذلك،
ومن الواضح
أننا كنا نتابع  الوضع
عن كثب
وآمل في الأفضل.
لدينا عدد كبير من
اللاجئين الأوكرانيين هنا في مولدوفا.
وأنتم تعلمون أن هناك
فرقًا واضحًا بين
أوكرانيا ومولدوفا في الوقت الحالي ولكن
لا يزال الناس قلقين.